as Avengers endgame careens toward
theaters the question every fan is
asking is who's going to put an end to
the mad Titan Thanos of all the
possibilities no one makes more sense
than the MC use first hero Iron Man is
it better to be feared or respected and
I say is it too much to ask for both the
Infinity stones may look pretty but they
proven pretty deadly to people who come
in contact with them even when they
aren't combined together in a big golden
glove in Thor the dark world Jane Foster
gets her life leached out of her thanks
to a close encounter with the reality
stone and in guardians of the galaxy
Peter quill was nearly annihilated by
the Power Stone until the other
Guardians stepped up and shared the
burden that's partly why fantasies ease
in wielding the stones is so unsettling
it seems like the mad Titan is just made
of stronger stuff however a few humans
have also been able to use the fully
powered Infinity Gauntlet in the comics
among these hallowed few is none other
than Tony Stark while the MCU has
diverged from its comics roots in more
than a few ways it's not hard to imagine
movie Tony wielding an Infinity Gauntlet
to revive his fallen comrades it's fun
to play along sure but we know they're
coming back one way or another you saw
the Spider Man trailer right if the
Avengers go through the trouble of
stealing thanasis gauntlets or somehow
make their own who would do the honor of
wearing it it's a pretty expensive piece
of jewelry so maybe it should be handled
by the highest paid person in the MCU it
can't come and be handed you know
otherwise I would not be environment
gentleman unlike some of the Avengers
Tony Stark is a self-made superhero
we're not talking about his inherited
wealth of course what makes Tony so
impressive is how he got himself his
powers he didn't become a superhero
thanks to science experiments a
radioactive spider or a deadbeat
celestial dad he just rolled up his
sleeves and did it Tony Stark already
builders
the cave with a bunch of scrubs the
first glimpse we've gotten of mr. stark
an end game looks pretty dire but we
definitely don't think Tony is dying out
there in the vacuum of space he's going
to puzzle out a way to get back to earth
and then put all his resources into
coming up with a solution whether it's a
time machine a thousand new suits or a
good guy sequel to Ultron we're mad
scientist's we've seen Tony's army of
backup suits already but don't forget
that he's also built custom suits for
war machine and spider-man so what would
happen if he built custom suits our gear
for more of the surviving Avengers maybe
combining his know-how with some Hank
Pym shrinking tech imagine Captain
America with some powerful Stark
designed armor making him in his shield
even stronger actually you don't need to
imagine it because it's straight from
the comics as is Pepper Potts his own
rescue armor which we might end up
seeing in the movie basically if Iron
Man can put up a pretty good fight one
on one using just his suit Thanos
doesn't stand a chance against a whole
teched-out team of Avengers Iron Man
might have put up a good fight against
Thanos but all the tricks in his
nanotech suit have got nothing on
Stormbreaker Thor's new axe forged by
the giant dwarf a tree out of a room
metal and a dash of Groot the weapon
managed to creep through Thanos his
chest when he was at full power nearly
ending the infinity war while it was
still in part one if one Asgardian
weapon could do so much damage a few
more might just finish the job
especially with Tony Stark collaborating
on the design this is another thing
that's happened before in the comics
specifically the event comic fear itself
in that story some of Marvel's best and
brightest get their own Asgardian
weapons courtesy of a stark Odin
collaboration while the MCU
Odin might be dead he was replaced as
the high father by four and with great
power there must also come the
responsibility to make radical new
weapons to kill aliens with if Eitri
survived Thanos is decimation it's not
crazy to imagine the Avengers going back
to rearm themselves with technically
enhanced godlike weaponry why not
Hulk couldn't beat Thanos the first time
but
if he had a sword like Hine dolls my old
man had a philosophy piece means having
a bigger stick than the other guy it's a
great line coming from the guys on the
sticks while the Avengers end games plot
details are still under wraps rumor has
it that the key to defeating Thanos will
heavily involve time travel the MC use
version of a cheat code supposedly the
film will feature the surviving Avengers
scrambling across time intersecting with
set pieces from previous movies like The
Avengers Battle of New York we don't
know if they're recruiting people from
the past
stealing Infinity stones from the
timestream or something else but if the
time-travel rumors are true then the
movie's going to feel almost like a
greatest hits collection of the MC use
first ten years one intriguing
possibility time-travel raises is a
possible reunion between Tony Stark and
his father Howard Stark it's not as
crazy as it seems if you remember papa
stark helped forge Captain America
shield played a vital role in the
formation of the shield organization and
was basically the 1940s version of his
genius playboy son flaws and all while
end game seems packed to the gills with
characters already it would definitely
be satisfying for Tony to finally get
closure with his dad and just maybe a
little family insights into how to save
the world check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite MCU
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]